[Musique]
cadenas et barbelés lancé cinéma
champlain semble être confiné à un
univers où seuls les pigeons sont admis
construit à la fin des années 40
édifices abandonnés à l'angle des rues
papineau et sainte-catherine aurait
pourtant mérité mieux
cette façade tout à fait étonnante avec
la tour la partie centrale cliff net on
est un peu dans le vocabulaire de
l'expressionnisme allemand des années 30
ou encore aux pays-bas la l'école d'arc
d'amsterdam et de très beaux détails qui
sont totalement inusité voici le cinéma
sont plaints tels que photographié
quelques jours avant son inauguration le
28 mars 1948
et puis dans cette publicité on annonce
que sa construction a coûté 450 mille
dollars
une véritable fortune à l'époque et que
ce sera le premier cinéma à montréal a
présenté des films en français
le maire draco présente son équipe dans
une grande salle de cinéma de la rue
sainte-catherine lieu de rencontres
politiques ou deux premières l'odéon
champlay cesse d'être une salle de
spectacle en 1986 une marquise illuminés
des bagnoles rutilantes le début des
années 90 l'auteur michel tremblay
faisait visiter à une équipe de radio
canada
ces salles de cinéma fétiche c'était
autrefois le faire maintenant c'est une
église à l'époque l'odéon champlain
était effectivement devenue une église
de type pentecôtiste ou le pasteur
alberto carbone réunissait ses fidèles
jusqu'en 2005 et jésus est vivant pour
vous depuis l'endroit est désert
les difficiles le terrain sont évalués
par la ville de montréal à deux millions
sept cent vingt-cinq mille dollars et la
compagnie son coeur pay plus de 150
mille dollars de taxes par année à la
ville
la compagnie d'ailleurs a refusé nous
laisser filmer à l'intérieur parce que
c'est trop dangereux dit elle qu'est ce
que ça donne à montréal au quartier au
centre-ville d'avoir un bâtiment dans
l'île m comme ça alors que peut-être
avec des ajustements réglementaires
on pourrait en faire des lieux
temporaires du genre artistique au
culturel ça nous donne le temps de
réfléchir à l'avenir plutôt que de subir
d'hellemmes comme ça parce que c'est pas
juste la propriété qui dépérissent et la
rue sainte-catherine qui subit les
effets de la compagnie suncor n'a pu me
dire pourquoi où l'essai s'était dit
fils à l'abandon ni si on avait des
projets pour celui ci
pourtant la ville de montréal nous a
répondu que dans le contexte où des
discussions sur l'avenir de cette
propriété privée sont en cours et que
ces discussions ne sont pas de nature
publique
il déclinait l'entrevue un autre édifice
à l'abandon vous un treuil à montréal
écrivez nous et nous tenterons de
répondre à vos questions ici émilie
dubreuil radio canada montréal